this summer will be the 35th anniversary
of when your most memorable films the
lost boys
do you have a standout memory
from the process of putting that project
together
well
i i do i think i got blamed for the
mullet for a long time as a lost voice
and and i'd like to clear the record
here that that i didn't necessarily want
that hairstyle but i i had really kind
of long hair
and joel schumacher the director wanted
my hair to be white
so that it would it would represent that
i was of the living dead
and so they dyed my hair white and i
just looked like a really young bad
wrestler
the hairstyle was awful so
and billy idol was really kind of hot at
the time and he was really cool and
and so i went to the hairstylist and all
i
kind of from joel had to do was i had to
keep my hair long
but billy idol's hair was much punkier
and cooler and yeah so i had them do
all of this kind of like billy idol and
then i kept it long at the back and i
think i created one of the worst
hairstyles known to mankind so i would
say
i'd like to apologize on your show for
that but that's that's one story that
has always made me laugh about lost boys
i'll accept uh my apology on
on behalf of the world you know what
though it's funny because it's like it
comes full circle to the canadian thing
because when i think of a mullet i think
hockey here
well
again
i think lost boys was very big with the
hockey community